if I can buy ads to promote Tim cast.com
and the projects we're doing and it has
the added benefit of winning the culture
War man I'll spend all my money let's
just let's roll you make me think Mr
Beast he'll actually take cameras in and
show the people crying with joy from
tasting fresh water for the first time
in their lives and things and you may
argue it's exploiting the people that
are getting the video taken of them but
he's giving away Wells and they attacked
him for it the media came after him well
he's an oppressive figure trying to help
people crazy guarantee he's he's
anything but and you should watch his
video where he brings 100 Wells to
people that are starving of fresh water
essentially dying you know having
distended stomachs and these little kids
this fly is driving me nuts are you guys
watching it's attacking everybody anyone
that starts to talk it's like I feel the
heat H work go straight to the speaker
holy
crap I just swatted and didn't squeeze I
had like some some sympathy for we open
the door and cross our fingers and he
leaves yeah I'll do that there you go
yeah the Flies attacking everybody